soon as I lost Consciousness which I
think is from that scientific
centrifugal force but then also just
fright you know what I mean so like
losing consciousness
I landed in the field right right next
to the runway about I'd say about six
feet from the paved Runway I landed in
the grass and I caused it indentation in
the earth holy dude you fell out of
a plane
so fast and hard jumped excuse me you
jumped out of a plane so fast and hard
and your parachute even though it was
still open wasn't proper and you still
hit the ground and left a dent in it
get in the earth man how are you talking
to me right now like oh bro literally
how do you have teeth you look good you
look good for someone who's missing back
to Earth
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
[Music]